y
[Música]
avanza informativo de france 24 el
presidente de chile sebastián piñera
ofreció su último discurso de cuenta
pública ante el congreso el mandatario
conservador ahora abarco gran diversidad
de temas incluyendo el levantamiento
social que llevó a la histórica
constituyente entre sus declaraciones
más destacadas dijo que ha llegado el
tiempo de aprobar el matrimonio
igualitario en el país a la fecha de las
parejas del mismo sexo pueden unirse
bajo una figura similar a la unión de
hecho
en colombia el comité del paro nacional
aseguró que ya se está dando de ese
escalamiento de los bloqueos en el país
en una muestra de voluntad para negociar
con el gobierno han pasado 33 días desde
el inicio del levantamiento social
contra el presidente iván duque y al
parecer unos 40 puntos serán reabiertos
al paso en las carreteras del país para
el comité de esta acción deja al
gobierno sin excusas para firmar pre
acuerdos que detengan las
manifestaciones en las que han fallecido
decenas de personas y hay miles de
denuncias de violencia policial entre
tanto las autoridades colombianas están
investigando a diez policías que
permitieron que civiles dispararan
contra manifestantes en calle
pero es de nuevo el país con la peor
cifra de fallecidos por kobe 19 per
cápita en todo el mundo el gobierno
revisó el número de decesos que deja la
pandemia y esto supone la adición de 111
mil nuevos muertos es decir las
defunciones casi que se triplicaron para
llegar ahora a los 180 mil 700
fallecidos tras el trabajo realizado por
un grupo técnico así las cosas el
territorio peruano tiene 551 muertos por
cada 100.000 habitantes superando de
lejos a hungría en donde hay 300 muertos
por cada 100.000 ciudadanos y que es la
nación que le sigue en la amarga
clasificación
se cumplen 100 años de la masacre de
tulsa oklahoma cuando una turba racista
atacó los hogares de un barrio
afroamericano dejando cientos de
personas fallecidas en uno de los peores
capítulos en la historia de violencia
racial del país el presidente yo wyden
visita hoy el lugar de la tragedia en un
acto de reconocimiento a los
sobrevivientes de greenwood la
conciencia sobre los asesinatos en tulsa
del 31 de mayo y primero de junio de
1921 que nos enseñaron en las clases de
historia ni se informaron en los
periódicos locales durante décadas ha
aumentado en los últimos años residentes
blancos dispararon y mataron a unas 300
personas afro y quemaron y saquearon
casas y negocios devastando una próspera
comunidad afroamericana después de que
una mujer blanca acusó a un hombre afro
de agresión a acusaciones que nunca fue
probada
noticias de israel faltan 24 horas para
que se cumpla el plazo del centrista ya
y la pide para formar un ejecutivo en
israel tras el previo fracaso de
benjamín netayahu en el intento luego de
elecciones no concluyentes el bloque
opositor sigue negociando para ultimar
los detalles del llamado gobierno de
cambio que acabaría con un bloqueo
político de más de dos años y con 12
años consecutivos de benjamín netayahu
como primer ministro
la coalición abarca partidos de todos
los espectros y se unió con la idea
común de sacar a netanyahu del poder su
ficha clave es naftalí bennett líder de
yamina y quien el domingo anunció su
apoyo al movimiento acordando ser primer
ministro por los primeros dos años antes
de rotar con lápiz
y en los deportes el italiano carlo
ancelotti se despidió del everton con un
agradecimiento y celebró su retorno al
real madrid' que dirigirá en reemplazo
de zinedine zidane ancelotti dijo que
hacer todo el reto con un equipo que
siempre está en su corazón firmará para
las tres próximas temporadas con el club
madrileño que espera revivir la emoción
de cuando el italiano llevó al equipo a
la conquista de la décima copa de europa
hasta que este avance siga con nosotros
en france 24